TIM ANDERSON: Hi, welcome
to Tech Trips From Teachers.
In this episode, we'll
focus on elementary literacy
and we're joined by Alanna
Mednick from Berkeley,
California.
Alanna has experience teaching
across all elementary school
grades and is also
co-authoring a book
on social emotional
development for students.
So Alanna, tell us why
technology's important
in the classroom
and, specifically,
with elementary literacy.
ALANNA MEDNICK:
Technology is everywhere.
Our students need to
be adept at using it.
With 30 students
in the classroom,
it's really difficult to meet
all their individual needs.
This technology
facilitates that process.
And with elementary
literacy, specifically, it's
a very complicated process.
Technology allows us to meet
these emerging readers needs.
TIM ANDERSON: And
speaking with a number
of different educators, we found
a few key themes that emerged.
For elementary
literacy apps, it's
important that they support
language development,
have differentiated content, and
engage all types of learners.
ALANNA MEDNICK: Language
development support
is essential.
Differentiated content
is very important
because it helps us meet each
student's individual need.
I'm also able to maximize
my own instructional time
by making sure that my
students are interacting
with something very useful.
Great apps engage all learners.
In my classroom, I have visual,
auditory, and kinesthetic
learners.
Ideally, students should
be able to see, hear,
and interact with the content.
TIM ANDERSON: Time
to take a look
at some apps that integrate
these elements really well.
ALANNA MEDNICK: The first
app we're looking at
is Endless Reader,
a great example
of language development.
The students are both able
to interact with the phonics,
the shape of the letters,
and the phonemic awareness,
the sound of the letters.
The program also builds
from letter and sound
to words to sentence building,
so it covers a large span
of student ability.
Raz-Kids is an excellent example
of differentiated content.
This app has 27 levels of
difficulty allowing students
to receive content that matches
their individual ability.
It's also very easy
for teachers to use.
All student content
and passwords
can be managed from
a single dashboard.
Booksy is an excellent
example of an app that
engages all types of learners.
Visual learners see
the words and pictures.
Auditory learners are
engaged because content
can be read aloud.
And student users can be
recorded while they're reading.
This also appeals to
the kinesthetic learners
who are naturally
interacting with the device.
TIM ANDERSON: So for
elementary literacy apps,
the key tips are developing
apps that support language
development, that have
differentiated content
and that engage all
types of learners.
For more episodes of
Tech Tips From Teachers,
check out the Google
Developers YouTube channel.
So we'd like to think Alanna
Mednick for joining us
for today's episode.
ALANNA MEDNICK:
I'm excited to see
more apps being developed to
better meet my students' needs.
TIM ANDERSON: We'll
see you next time
on Tech Tips From Teachers.